und darüber zu gerd joachim von follower
in den bundestag hat von verlor viel los
heute bei ihnen
ja und der bundestag fängt hier am
mittwoch traditionell mit der
sogenannten generaldebatte
an und wir haben eine neue
bundesregierung das ist also die erste
generaldebatte für kanzler scholz und es
sind bewegte tage normalerweise würde
man ja gerne jetzt auf 100 tage bilanz
zurück gucken 106 tage ist er jetzt im
amt aber schon am 79 tag hat sich jeder
code jede koordinate verändert denn da
war die kriegserklärung von putin
gegenüber der ukraine und seitdem ist
alles anders die parameter die 177
seiten die die ampel ausgehandelt hat
davon kann so wohl nichts mehr bleiben
wie es dasteht und genau vor 100 tagen
nämlich am donnerstag vor einer woche da
hat die residenz die hier im deutschen
bundestag gesprochen und danach hat der
kanzler geschwiegen ein fehler wie viele
finden und wir wollen jetzt darüber
reden über diese bilanz der ersten tage
wenn man die überhaupt ziehen kann mit
zwei jüngeren abgeordneten die ich mir
eingeladen habe die heute garantiert
hier im plenum nicht sprechen werden
aber bei uns bei phoenix ich begrüße
ganz herzlich falko mohrs von der spd
mitglied im wirtschaftsausschuss und
tillmann kuban von der cdu/csu auch
vorsitzender der jungen union
und weil die generaldebatte immer so ist
dass die opposition vorliegt frage ich
heute ausnahmsweise mal erst ein
oppositionspolitiker herr kuban wenn wir
das mal betrachtet ich habe sogar ein
bisschen angerissen was war für sie die
größte enttäuschung oder die größte
fehler leistung dieser erst 106 tage und
haben sie auch was positives gefunden
bei der handel ist erstmal muss man
sagen so wie sie es auch schon an
moderiert haben es ist alles anders
seitdem wladimir putin diesen absolut
ihren krieg gegen die ukraine führt und
deswegen kann ich verstehen dass wir in
einer besonderen lage sind und in dieser
besonderen lage muss man glaube ich auch
besonders reagieren und deswegen kann
ich es absolut verstehen dass wir heute
keine bilanz über die ersten 100 tage
über die ersten projekte führen können
weil es eben eine komplett andere lage
ist etwas das wir seit vielen vielen
jahrzehnten auf europäischem boden
glücklicherweise eigentlich nicht mehr
erlebt haben wo ich mir hätte nicht
vorstellen können dass wir es noch
einmal auf europäischem boden erleben
trotzdem ist es natürlich so dass ich
mir auch gewünscht hätte letzte woche es
war wirklich ein beschämender moment das
dann auch von seiten des kanzlers darauf
reagiert wird wenn man direkt
angesprochen wird etwas was viele gar
nicht gesehen haben aber das volumen
selensky unmittelbar nach dem er
gesprochen hat sofort aufgestanden ist
und gegangen ist war ein akt auch ein
klares signal gegen deutschland und das
auftreten der bundesregierung in diesen
fällen wir haben einfach viel zu wenig
geliefert wir haben beim thema swift
ausschluss viel zu lange gewartet und
waren die bremser wir haben beim thema
waffenlieferungen sechs tage geschlagene
sechs tage gebraucht bis sie endlich mal
in der ukraine war da ist viel
nachholbedarf wenn ich mir anschaue was
momentan beim embargo passiert wenn ich
mir anschaue was bei der
eu-mitgliedschaft passiert da ist
wirklich viel aufholbedarf und da muss
die ampel liefern und ganz kurz was
positives
definitiv dass man am anfang wie ich
finde sehr gut reagiert hat die erste
rede von olaf scholz auch das auftreten
wie ich finde von robert habeck oder
annalena baerbock finde ich
bemerkenswert dass robert habeck in
katar gemacht hat das muss man als
grüner erstmal machen ja hier muss ein
lob da an den kanzler und das wird ja
von vielen so empfunden die rede die er
da am 27
februar gehalten hat das war eine
zeitenwende hat ja selber gesagt
die kritik haben sie gerade gehört wenn
er sie denn hier direkt aufgestanden ist
es mir gar nicht aufgefallen dann war es
vielleicht tatsächlich gar nicht
sinnvoll da weiter zu reden dabei hätte
man nicht mindestens eine halbe stunde
unterbrechen müssen um sich das setzen
zu lassen also erstmal noch mal gut
morgen auch von meiner seite und danke
für die chance heute morgen habe ich den
finger nochmal einzuordnen und wenn ich
mir das gerade anhöre dann muss ich
sagen ich bin sehr froh dass der
bundeskanzler haben der erst denkt und
dann handelte und nicht andersrum weil
ich habe immer den eindruck dass sich
hier die opposition mit forderungen sehr
impulsiver selber überholt und ich
glaube in zeiten wo wir über krieg und
frieden in europa sprechen ist
ehrlicherweise sinnvoll klar vor
abzuwägen verantwortungsvoll sich die
dinge zurecht zu legen und dann eben
auch klare kante zu zeigen und wenn ich
jetzt höre das ja gerade auch die rede
zur zeitenwende als der positiv der
ersten 100 tage wahrgenommen wurde dann
finde ist das der beleg dafür das ist
nämlich richtig und wichtig ist erst zu
überlegen dann sehr klare linien zu
ziehen und dann das entsprechend auch
abzuhandeln und wenn ich etwa auf letzte
woche komme ich finde das zeigt ja auch
ehrlicherweise dass die union ihre runde
noch überhaupt nicht gefunden hat denn
wir haben letzte woche zwei mal im
deutschen bundestag über die ukraine
über die folgen über den krieg
gesprochen und dann nach so einer wie
ich finde beeindruckenden emotionalen
rede des ukrainischen präsidenten hier
so ein klamauk zu veranstalten so hab
ich das nämlich ehrlicherweise empfunden
wird dem auch überhaupt nicht gerecht
ich fand trotzdem das auch schwierig
gibt es offen zu ich finde werden uns in
der tat noch mal vielleicht doch sammeln
müssen wir gegen das auch so ich musste
mich sagen wir nach der debatte mehr ist
der übergang auch schwer gefallen und
ich verstehe aber auch dass das vielen
anderen so gehe da muss man auch von
ihnen was ist nicht wirklich gut
gelaufen die 106 tage die regierung
wurde vom ersten tag an voll gefordert
von den krisen und die haben uns viele
dinge anders vorgestellt ich finde
übrigens dass wir trotz allem dinge wie
den mindestlohn eingeführt haben bzw
erhöht haben auf 12 euro was ja vielen
millionen menschen gerade im osten
gerade frauen hilft zeigt er aber sie
haben das vorhin gesagt dass das
programm oder das was für uns als
polizei vertrag ja vorgenommen haben
eben auch nicht einfach beiseite gelegt
wird sondern trotz dieser
herausforderung der erst 100 tage genau
diese wichtigen elementaren dinge auf
vorangetrieben worden und ich glaube
aber auch wir sehen das mit corona das
mit dem ukraine krieg mit jetzt auch den
wirtschaftlichen folgen die auf uns
zukommen
einfach echt ein riesenbatterie von der
rosa sonst eigentlich meine es ist ja
richtig dass wir in dieser zeit mit
heißem herz aber mit kühlem kopf agieren
nur sie müssen schon auch sehen dass von
den menschen die menschen von dem
bundeskanzler verlangen dass er führt
und wenn wir an schauen dass wir seit
dem 27 februar wir haben heute mitte
märz seit über drei wochen nichts gehört
haben in diesem parlament weil finde ich
das relativ wenig finde dass die
menschen das auch verdient haben dass er
zu ihnen spricht und dass er in eine
linie gibt er hat das am 27 februar wie
ich finde gut getan das habe ich auch
gelobt aber
jetzt in den letzten wochen war sehr
viel ruhe und er sehr viel chaos wenn
wir uns anschauen was ministerium von
frau lamprecht los ist was beim thema
verteidigung passiert da ist viel
nachholbedarf
verlassen werden darf ich will
was quatsch ist dass sich die menschen
selbst entscheiden das müssen sie ja
nicht wissen sie eigentlich sogar trotz
der bundeskanzler hat nichts gesagt und
das ist zu wenig also die deswegen habe
ich mich an guttenberg und anderen steht
jedoch nicht gerade für den aufbruch in
der bundeswehr zu finden sich zum
positiven und ich finde dass hier ein
klarer schlussstrich gezogen wurde von
tron lambrecht die das aus meiner fest
die wird übrigens sehr gut macht die
reformen jetzt auch im beschaffungswesen
angestrebt die exekutiert die 100
milliarden euro als sondervermögen jetzt
auf uns zukommt ich würde mir wünschen
dass die union da am ende mitgemacht
weil sie sind die die diejenigen gerade
im regen stehen lassen sie sich
eigentlich darauf verlassen dass das
sondervermögen für eine bessere
ausstattung wir waren immer so sie
wissen dass sie sind ja schon länger im
parlament sie wissen dass das wir schon
simple sache jetzt auch mal wird sein
geheimnis bleiben
ich muss manchmal 19 jahren vierter
hinter kuba erinnere nur kurz daran
einen satz ich erinnere nur kurz da dran
wir haben uns gestritten über sechs
drohnen steigen um 6 drohen sie haben
immer die ablehnung sie haben immer die
ablehnung dazu plädiert sie haben immer
das ganze verweigert und das ist eben
kein
verantwortungsvoller umgang mit den
soldatinnen und soldaten die in einen
krieg meine herren ich habe extra junge
leute eingeladen damit er sich auch ein
bisschen zur sache gehen aber so wollte
ich es eigentlich nicht haben denn so
hat der bürger ja nichts davon zu
schauen wir mal auf die probleme die
sich jetzt ergeben zum beispiel die
risiken energiekosten die es gibt da hat
die koalition ein erstes entlastungs
paket geschnürt im moment gibt es diese
neue gruppe da wird heute morgen
gemeldet da gibt es einen durchbruch der
heute abend von den chefs geeint wird
oder auch nicht man liegt doch noch weit
auseinander können sie dazu irgendwas
sagen was dieses volumen zum beispiel
angeht was da an entlastung diskutiert
wird also erstmal völlig richtig es gab
ein erstes würde es gibt ein erstes
entlastungspaket da reden über 13
milliarden euro da geht es
beispielsweise um den bereich energie
kosten eeg wird vorzeitig abgeschafft
also dass die umlage die für die
erneuerbaren energien dort gezahlt wird
zum ersten siebten fällt die weg wir
haben die heizkosten unterstützung für
viele millionen menschen in diesem land
eingeführt bzw deutlich erhöht damit die
ja noch mal verdoppelt hier auch im
parlament das ist nun mal so zwei dinge
wir haben zusätzliche hilfen für
familien und was wir aber sehen ist dass
diese erste paket eben aus unserer sicht
noch nicht ausreichend deswegen hat die
neunergruppe eine sehr breite und wie
ich finde sehr fundierte vorarbeit
gemacht haben uns aber auch darauf
verständigt sie kennen das aus den
koalitionsverhandlungen dass wir aber
auch stillschweigend jetzt über die
ergebnisse vereinbart haben weil ich
glaube am ende geht es ja nicht darum
wer als erstes irgendwie sonders
populistisch oder plakativ dinge nach
außen bringt sondern dass wir immer am
ende wirklich etwas finden was
zielgerichtet wirkt was sozial
ausgewogen wirkt was direkt bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern ankommt und was
auch nicht wie andere vorschläge die von
der union kommen europarechtswidrig sind
das kann man sagen die union hat ja mit
zu fragen die maut erfahrung damit dinge
europarechtswidrig erfolg zu schlagen
schauen sie aber ihre vorschläge diese
machen welche sind denn jetzt
europarechtswidrig
lernen möchte ich ihnen mal möchte ich
immer ein paar beispiele nennt gucken
sie mal bitte in unserer europäischen
nachbarländer dort wurden auch die
steuern gesenkt andere haben es schon
getan sie wehren sich dagegen aber ich
finde es spannend dass sie den vorschlag
von herrn lindner schon als populistisch
abtun wenn sie sagen dass der tank
rabatt der jahr ausgeschlossen war wie
sie es nennt das der dann eingehen
angeblich populistisch war zeigt nicht
wirklich viel an da will ich nochmal
eingaben sehr schön so ein
innenpolitischer streit bringt aber
niemanden weiter vor allen dingen auch
die frage warum ist sind wir nicht so
abhängig geworden von russischer energie
das war doch sicherlich ein riesenfehler
der letzten jahre jetzt wissen wir es
alle aber hätte man das nicht schon
früher ändern müssen ostring zwei als
stichwort war ein riesenfehler beide
fraktionen die heute morgen versammelt
sind haben immer einen hinterhof streams
2 gestanden im gegensatz zu der
damaligen opposition
kuban das war doch ein versagen der
regierung merkel was heute sich bitter
rächt oder ich bin erst neu in diesem
parlament nichtsdestotrotz ist es
richtig dass cdu und csu genauso wie die
spd in den letzten jahren hinter diesem
projekt gestanden sicherlich aufgrund
der eindrücke die wir einfach auch in
den letzten jahr ca gehabt am anfang der
2000er jahre hat wladimir putin hier im
deutschen bundestag gesprochen man hat
eine app is meant politik gemacht man
hat das vorangetrieben und gesagt wir
werden gemeinsam uns einig sein und über
wirtschafts über wirtschaftliche
annäherung auch eine politische
annäherung an russland schaffen man muss
so offen und ehrlich sein diese politik
ist gescheitert
und genau deswegen brauchen wir jetzt
ein umdenken wir müssen uns anschauen
wer sind unsere handelspartner
wer sind unsere partner für die nächsten
jahre weil es auf dauer nicht so sein
kann dass wir unsere sicherheits
dividende aus den usa nehmen unsere
energie dividende aus russland nehmen
und unsere wohlstands dividende aus
china das kann nicht der weg der zukunft
sein muss die frage ist ja wie lange
nehmen wir denn die energie aus russland
viele in deutschland fordern ja dass wir
das beenden damit putin noch weniger
geld hat denn so finanzieren wir den
krieg mit also würde da nicht
konsequenzen jetzt not tue was haben sie
das ist ja genau aller dinge wo ich am
anfang gesagt habe es ist gut eben klar
zu denken und dann auch klar zu
entscheiden und wir sind stand heute
leider muss man wirklich sagen auch
viele
energieimporte aus russland abhängig was
wir jetzt machen als bundesregierung
seit vielen wochen und monaten ist eben
sehr klar zuschauen wie können wir diese
abhängigkeit reduzieren es erwähnt
worden dass gerade auch bundesminister
habeck er unterwegs war um eben auch
zusätzliche quellen für uns zu
erschließen das ist alles nicht einfach
das muss man wirklich sagen aber das ist
eben genau der weg weil ein sofortiger
stopp von importen würde uns am ende
sehr hart treffen und da müssen wir
jetzt vorbereitet sein was kann ja sein
dass die andere seite irgendwann die
stadt darf ich sie habe ich mal fragen
ist sehen dass ihrer meinung nach
sinnvoll dass wir aus der abhängigkeit
der russen hin zu anderen
autokratischen systemen gehen wie die
arabischen emirate oder kuwait und uns
von denen dann abhängig machen wo da die
menschenrechte dort täglich mit füßen
getreten werden können wir uns solche
moralischen überlegungen eigentlich noch
leisten wir brauchen ja die energien
also ich würd mir wünschen wir könnten
das alleine mit partnern und freunden
wie den niederlanden aus eigenen quellen
oder norwegen heraus decken die realität
ist doch aber die er muss sie mich
verstehen dass das alleine nicht reichen
wird und deswegen schauen wir dass wir
es eben besser diversifizieren also
breiter aufstellen nicht die fehler der
vergangenheit noch mal machen nicht
solche abhängigkeiten kommen und das
finde ich es der richtige weg wir können
uns noch eine tankfüllung leisten auch
wenn es schmerzlich ist an der
tankstelle die deutschen stöhnen unter
den steigenden preisen das betrifft ja
auch lebensmittel und alles andere das
ist ein riesenproblem für menschen die
wenig geld haben zum beispiel heizung
deswegen noch mal die frage energie ist
der schlüssel der zukunft
ich bin immer ein bisschen verwirrt wenn
ich vom bundesfinanzminister höhere also
eine senkung der steuer auf mineralöl-
geht nicht komisch im ausland geht es
bei uns nicht wenn ich aus dem
umweltministerium höher also
verlängerung atomkraft geht auch nicht
dann müssen wir neue brennstäbe aus
england kaufen warum geht das immer bei
uns alles nicht beim thema tank rabatt
oder bei der frage der steuersenkung
habe ich eine andere meinung habe ich
eine andere auffassung und sie haben es
richtigerweise angesprochen es gibt
andere länder um uns herum die haben
bereits die steuern gesenkt deswegen
sollten wir das auch tun die union
schlägt vor dass wir das von 19% auf 7%
bei der mehrwertsteuer umsatzsteuer
senken das würde beispielsweise an der
tanksäule eine konkrete entlastung von
40 cent pro liter bedeuten und das ist
ein konkreter vorschlag der ist
abgelehnt worden wir sind sehr gespannt
was die ampel heute vorschlägt ich
glaube wir müssen umdenken und am ende
müssen alle heiligen kühe die wir den
letzten jahren aus einem wohlstands
empfinden heraus diskutiert haben auf
den tisch und dann zu einer gemeinsamen
lösung kommt die union ist da
gesprächsbereit weil ich glaube schon
dass wir einen energiekonsens brauchen
im allgemeinen die zeit ist leider schon
wieder abgelaufen vielen dank für diese
bewegte debatte die aber in der sache
natürlich nicht weiterbringt denn es
gibt ganz viele sachprobleme die der
kanzler die die ampel lösen muss und
darüber wird sicherlich gleich hier
diskutiert werden hoffentlich
sachorientiert dann auch die
lösungsvorschläge von beiden seiten wir
warten jetzt auf jeden fall gleich mal
auf den oppositionsführer friedrich merz
der die debatte hier heute eröffnen wird
und dann wird der bundeskanzler
antworten bleiben sie bei uns danach
gibt es dann das außenressort das
verteidigungsressort also wirklich
spannende debatten heute hier im
deutschen bundestag und ich geh bereiten